david davis uh former brexit secretary
uh who is the conservative mp
for haltom price and howden is with us
now hello to you mr dave it's great
to talk to you you're one of the rebels
are you going to win
well i think so uh certainly if uh all
those who want to vote for us
are allowed to we will win um i'm pretty
confident we'll win
whatever the whips try and do if if the
if the
amendment is called of course it changed
your tune though haven't you because you
didn't used to agree
with the 0.7 gdp i've got a quote from
you here well i don't actually agree
with the government this is in 2012.
the government's policy on uh the 0.7
i think that is just nonsense we should
spend
the money on aid that needs to be spent
on aid why have you changed your mind
well what i said at the time and you're
quite right as a public accounts
committee chairman
i said this is too fast an increase it
would lead to inefficiencies
but what we're looking at today is cuts
that will be massive cuts
in provision of clean water dirty water
kills more children than probably
anything else in the world other than
malaria maybe
we're seeing massive cuts to food
support about a quarter of a million
people 250 000 people will be
facing starvation without that what
we're talking about and big cuts to the
biggest emergency areas in the world one
of your
speakers earlier talked about the
the reduction to yemen the biggest
emergency with the world has
all of these things will lead to loss of
life probably tens of thousands of
children will die
as a result of these cuts nobody else
amongst the g7 is doing this uh germany
now has caught up with 0.7
france will uh pass that uh this year as
well
the americans are increasing their
spending by 16 billion
a year all of them face similar economic
issues to us
we've actually got the fastest recovery
economic recovery rate
uh in the modern world uh and and as a
result
why are we doing this thing which will
lead to the deaths of large numbers of
children
but richie sunak would say in response
to that that the economic outlook
is still uncertain at this stage we
can't
afford it when we can it's only
temporary when we can afford it again
then of course we'll put it back to 0.7
and it does look as though the public
agrees 60 percent of the public when
they were asked said yep
charity starts at home well it depends
how you
how you put the question to them if you
tell them the consequence will be tens
of thousands of children will die i
think you get a rather different answer
if you say oh should we spend on
something at home first
of course you'll get that answer the
simple truth is
that this is not necessary it's less
than one percent of the borrowings that
uh that risk is going in for this year
and as a result it doesn't make economic
sense and as you've heard from lisa
nandy and others
it will undermine our position a very
very hard
one position uh with so-called soft
power our respect in the world if you
like
it will undermine that too but for me
the issue is about lives
children's lives and frankly even if it
was an unpopular policy i would still
stand up for it
i don't want to be a member of a
government or a supporter of a
government
that is effectively deciding to uh
lead to tens of thousands of deaths of
small children
and it does appear that many
backbenchers agree
with you i think 45 need
to vote against the government in or in
favor of the amendment in order
to change the direction of this uh uk
foreign aid to that end i believe that
the chancellor's been ringing people
uh over the weekend mps personally
um to ask whether they will change their
minds did he contact you
no he didn't um he probably realized it
would be it would be a futile exercise
but that tells you
uh that we are in winning territory
because you know the chancellor doesn't
spend his weekend calling out back
ventures normally
uh and and we are in winning territory
if this is put to the vote i believe
we'll win
and the government will have to defend
this policy and that will save lives
yeah embarrassing for the prime minister
to potentially lose
a vote uh in his own house of commons
ahead of
the g7 he's going to have a bloody nose
isn't he heading down to cornwall
yeah well i'm sorry about that but you
know i i really don't want to see him
embarrassed nobody does actually
when we're when we're hosting g7 but the
simple truth is that this should have
been brought to the house so this was in
our manifesto
uh the 0.7 we were the leaders in the
world doing it
uh and it should have if he wanted to
change it he should have brought it to
the house of commons and allowed the
house to rule on it
uh i think actually he would have lost
and we would still a bit 0.7 today if
he'd done that which is why he didn't do
it
and as a result what he's got is a
policy that the uh the
one of the best directors of public
prosecutions in modern times
uh ken mcdonald said is unlawful so
we've got an unlawful policy we need to
put right
if he'd if he'd come to the house first
we would have corrected at the beginning
unfortunately now we've got to do it
when we can do it which is today
one of the other issues he's going to
have to deal with of course is the dog's
dinner that is the
uh border in the irish sea we heard from
the president you were brexit secretary
of the
president brexit minister saying oh it's
harder than we
anticipated uh it was going to be
despite three former
prime minister as uh george mitchell the
cbi so many others explaining that
let me just play this clip to you if
you'll indulge me uh from the uh
government minister this morning when i
put that to her
lord frost is absolutely trying to get
it sorted and he was in ireland last
week
and doing exactly that it is very
difficult on the ground
in terms of trade um and you know it is
important that we ensure that we do have
uh trade between um between the uk
and and uh ireland between between
england and ireland
and it is really important that we saw
that and lord frost is doing exactly
that but you understand
that it does look as though you
underestimated the complexities
of this agreement well as it has panned
out on the ground it is more difficult
than we anticipated and we do need to
sort out that trade arrangement
we're going to be paying the price for
many years to come because our trade is
affected
imports and exports are affected
northern ireland is particularly
affected
and i really hope the government can
sort out some of these problems as
quickly as possible
because it's about jobs it's about
livelihoods it's about the supply of
food and everything else it's got to be
sorted out
mr davis to what extent do you accept
responsibility for this mess
well it's one of the things i resigned
over you may remember
i did predict to the prime minister at
the time when she conceded the so-called
full alignment wording
that this was problematic not what we
promised
and would lead to difficulties in the
future and that's exactly what we're
seeing as i say that's why i resigned
uh and after that checkers meeting a
couple of years back
isn't that i suppose my question is
shouldn't you have stayed to try to sort
it out
it wasn't possible once you got to the
point of uh
agreeing the alignment of northern irish
regulations with southern irish
regulations you are creating a border of
one sort or another you're creating a
border
which would end up falling in the irc
would be much simpler to create an
invisible border
between the north and south of ireland
that was the original policy
that's what theresa may abandoned i'm
afraid and that as i say in due course
led to me resigning which was
the only way to break the only way to
bring it to an end frankly because
as it was her cabinet was determined to
carry on with this policy which would
lead to where we are today
it will be resolved it's difficult and
it but it will be resolved because
everybody wants to resolve it
but it's an unnecessary debt difficulty
and it had
a couple of years of negotiation to the
overall
outcome that was going to be my question
what what is the resolution how do you
see it being resolved because of course
in the wings
we've got the leaders of free world
saying unless you sort that out
forget a trade deal with the united
states
well the the secret goes way way back if
you if you cast your mind back
right the beginning of the negotiations
both the
irish uh head of taxation the head of
their equivalent of the hmrc
and our head of hmrc you said it was
perfectly possible
to manage with an invisible border
between the north and the south
under different arrangements uh and
similarly
you know with technical mechanisms you
can do the same here trusted trader
arrangements
uh agreed agreed regulatory arrangements
that sort of thing
it's possible to do it it would just
take a lot of detail and it'll take
i'm guessing frankly because i'm no
longer that close to the
negotiation but i think probably a
couple of years of detailed
onward negotiation to facilitate all of
these things
going back and forth it shouldn't have
been necessary uh it shouldn't have
happened but it happened because
uh we conceded to an aggressive uh
eu stance on this which when we
shouldn't have done it but it's not it's
not insoluble
it's practically resolvable but it'll
take a year or two
and you're pleased it's not you having
to fix it
no i'm not pleased it's not me having a
picture that isn't why i resigned i
resigned to make a point
to actually bring to a to crystallize if
you like the problem
the outcome was the government changed
boris came in
we got the outcome we got which is
slightly better than what was there
before
and we will get a resolution eventually
that's that's that's
that's that's worth a resignation even
my own
david davis great to talk to you thanks
for joining us this morning